hello
this way
not only the chip shortage but the whole
distribution
chain is
in my view it's i think probably
produced more cancellations of
exhibitors than anything having to do
with covet at this point we've heard
from exhibitors that have are not
participating
because they just can't get their
product they can't get their prototypes
together things like that and that's
definitely been
an issue
[Music]
there is
based on research we've done in the
industry
a sense that it's not going to be solved
quickly
it's um
i think people are more optimistic six
months ago when we did our first set of
research than they were six months later
um
so it's it's an overhang for the
industry
when they
get their show registration
credentials they'll be given uh the
opportunity for free tests
and throughout the show um they'll be
able to take them so it's something
that's
it's
just one more layer uh added on so
people feel comfortable and safe but
when you're on the show premises
themselves i think people will feel
pretty comfortable
[Music]
it's a very exciting time and we have a
huge number of companies plus we also
have
new categories that we have never had
before like food technology space
technology nfts it's a
really
wonderful time and there's so many parts
of the show i mean the health technology
portion is another portion it's totally
huge because there's been such a focus
on health technology and innovation for
the last two years and here's a chance
to display it and so that's really
really exciting
the biggest hit we're seeing
from this
all the the covet is for people that are
not vaccinated and we felt we addressed
that problem
in uh in july when we made our decision
so
those that didn't want to come those
that are not vaccinated are not coming
so the you know the
we feel very good about providing
a pretty safe environment on the shelf
premises
vivo las vegas fever las vegas
viva
viva
las vegas thank you thinker buzz rock
and roll baby